we've got West Brown who I think all of
you know Wes is the the subject of the
book that Bob schneller has written and
you'll get a chance to hear from Wes
I've had the occasion to spend some time
with Wes over the last two or three
weeks and different acade in different
settings I will tell you this is a great
story but a lot of people think Bob it's
a story about the Naval Academy or it's
a story about the brigade of Midshipmen
or it's a story about the Navy it is all
of those things but it's a great deal
more this is an American story it's a
story about American history good and
bad American history it's a story that
needed to be told we're very lucky that
Bob sneller was selected to tell a story
bob is an award-winning publicist author
biographer works at the naval historical
center center where we want to make sure
everybody knows you'd on the payroll
there none of the proceeds of the book
signing or the purchase of these books
not one dime goes to Bob and not one Don
goes to West and not one dime comes the
Alumni Association we're just proud to
be part of this story about American
history Naval Academy history enabling
his naval history and without further
ado I'd like for you all to welcome to
overall I just commander Wes Brown
but his biographer Bob snow welcome
thank you George afternoon ladies and
gentlemen thank you for coming I'm going
to speak today about how breaking the
color barrier came to be and then
commander Brown is going to say a few
words and then we'll open the floor for
questions and answers I came to work for
the naval historical center in 1991
fresh out of graduate school I spent the
first several years there writing a
history of the US Navy and the Gulf War
which was eventually published his
shield and sword in 1995 as I was
finishing that book I began thinking
about the subject for my next book at
the time the Navy was drawing down from
its Cold War levels of ships and men and
I thought it might be useful to do a
study on the demobilization of the Navy
after World War Two to see how the
personnel policies of the mid-1940s
affected the Navy's readiness for the
Korean War I thought that that was a
sort of a parallel situation to the
situation in the early to mid 90s and it
would yield some insights into that
situation in the 90s I soon learned that
one of the most significant policy
changes of the early era post-world war
ii era was integration of the armed
services in fact during World War two
the United States Navy's personnel
policy underwent a revolution changing
from exclusion of african-americans
outside the Messman x' branch where all
of black sailor could expect to do was
to wait on officers and cook their food
to full integration at least as the
policy was written but not not
necessarily in practice well I was doing
my initial research on this subject
Wesley brown was serving as a member of
the Secretary of the Navy's Advisory
Subcommittee on naval history which came
to the center every year to evaluate our
historical programs and make
recommendations to the secretary because
I was recording the minutes of the
meeting and helped write the report to
the secretary I had a chance to meet
commander Brown since he was the first
African American Naval Academy graduate
and I was doing a
Annelle policies studied during the
period when he was a midshipman I
thought it would be logical to ask him
for an interview and he graciously
consented I conducted my first interview
with commander Brown on 19 December 1995
a cold rainy day after commander brown
introduced me to his right as his wife
crystal we retired to his study and I
set up the tape recorder and began the
interview I had a list of 75 questions
and shortly after we started the
interview mrs. Brown told us that she
was going to go out and do some shopping
she returned some time later and looked
in and noticed that we hadn't moved from
our original positions and lunch time
had long passed and neither of us had
thought about food so she offered
graciously to make us lunch and as I
recall we had some chicken and a nice
salad that first interview went on for
six hours and and Commander Brown
graciously answered each one of those 75
questions and he never got tired I found
his story to be a lot more interesting
than the subject I was working on so I
decided to write a booklet about his
experiences at the Naval Academy the
booklet was slated to appear in the
naval historical centers Navy in the
modern world series which is a
publication that's about the size of a
piece of paper heavily illustrated about
fifty manuscript paper print pages
originally this was supposed to be a
temporary diversion from the personnel
policy study in my wasa proved the
subject and I began doing the research
in mid-1995 for the Naval Academy
integration study and I soon learned
that not only has little historical
attention been paid to integration of
the Naval Academy but there's been
little written about integration of the
Navy writ large in the mid-1990s when I
first started doing the research there
were only a couple of books out on
integration of the Armed Services as a
whole one book on integration of the
Navy that was published before Commander
Brown graduated and a handful of
monographs on race in the arm sir
in the 19th century as for integration
of the Academy there were a paragraph or
a line or two in books and two maybe
three articles and proceedings and other
places on integration of the Academy
exclusively so as I dug deeper into the
context of Wesley Browns Academy
experiences I soon realized that I had
stumbled into an untouched goldmine of
resource material records on African
Americans at the Naval Academy
stretching from reconstruction through
World War two exist the nimitz library
at the yard on the Naval Academy the
National Archives the Library of
Congress the Chicago Historical Society
numerous smaller repositories in
Washington DC and a host of other
institutions black newspapers for
example particularly from the late 20s
through the 1940s proved in an
especially rich resource on the black
community's efforts to foster
integration in the Armed Services
I learned that five african-americans
had become Midshipmen before Brown
matriculated all were treated very badly
to say the least by other Midshipmen
because of their race and each one left
the Academy under dubious circumstances
and the Academy administration to
varying degrees condone the ill
treatment these first five Midshipmen
received I also learned that the black
community had been trying to integrate
the Naval Academy since the 1870s
african-americans not only one of the
same educational and career
opportunities that the Academy afforded
the majority but they also wanted to
prove that they were capable of
competing with white people on one of
America's toughest proving grounds civil
rights leaders hoped that if black
people demonstrated themselves capable
of graduating it would undermine the
justification for segregation in other
words civil rights advocates viewed
integration of the Naval Academy
step towards gaining full civil rights
full equality for African Americans in
mid-1996 I talked this over with my boss
and proposed expanding the booklet into
a book the book would examine Browns
experiences at the Naval Academy within
the historical context of his
predecessors experiences the evolution
of the Navy's racial policies from
reconstruction through World War two and
the black community's efforts to break
the color barrier at the academy
my boss approved the idea in that
post-world War two the mobilization
project was sort of permanently shelved
meanwhile I pressed on with the research
after our first interview
commander brown sat for five more
interviews and answered many other
questions over the phone having this
level of access to a research subject is
a wonderful thing and a rare thing for
his historian I had written before this
project about the Civil War and Desert
Storm and I couldn't interview the Civil
War people I was writing about because
they were all dead and I interviewed a
number of Admirals for the Gulf War book
but I just couldn't call him on the
phone whenever I had a question in
addition to interviewing commander Brown
I tried to contact every living
midshipman who was in Browns battalion
the 4th battalion during his plebe year
and I sent each each one a questionnaire
one of the first people I contacted was
Jimmy Carter who was a first classmen
when Brown was a plea and who ran
cross-country with brown Carter didn't
give me an interview but he did sent me
a letter that included this statement
quote there were a few upper classmen
who tried to give Midshipmen Brown
undeserved demerits
end quote I enclose the letter that
President Carter had sent to me along
with the questionnaire referencing the
statement the questions to all those
Midshipmen from the fourth battalion I
received a lot of replies particularly
from Browns company 16th company and I
learned many things that Brown had never
known about that he had no idea was
going on
was a midshipman particularly the effort
of a group of first classmen to run him
out of the Academy and there was another
effort by a slightly larger small group
of first classmen to defeat the efforts
of the first group the best evidence for
this campaign to get brown or the the
most graphic evidence is Browns conduct
record by most accounts including his
battalion officers and I managed to get
a chance to talk to both of Browns
battalion officers through the mail and
one in person
graduates of the class of 35 but by most
accounts Brown was a squared-away
midshipman yet he received a hundred and
three demerits during the first semester
and only five during the second totaling
a hundred and eight for plebe year which
is evidence corroborated by the oral
histories and interviews that I did
questionnaires that I received that yes
there was an effort to get Brown and
that it was stopped and it was an effort
by racist first classmen who didn't want
him to graduate during the course of
this research I was also able to
interview George treiber's who was the
fifth african-american midshipman who
entered the Naval Academy in the summer
of 1937 but less did less than a month
in the early phases of my research I
naively believed that once Wesley brown
broke the color barrier integration of
the Academy was accomplished I said
about interviewing African American
graduates of the classes of 52 through
1969 at first with the view towards
finding out how Brown paved the way for
those who followed I also started doing
documentary research into the Naval
Academy's racial policy during this
period I learned that during this period
the Academy admitted an average of three
blacks per year and graduated an average
of two I also found out that the Naval
Academy had no minority recruiting
program before 1965 so in short Brown's
graduation marked the beginning of the
integration of the Naval
not its accomplishment so in 1997 I
proposed expanding the scope of the
project again and my boss said yes and
ultimately I wound up carrying the story
through the class of 1999 as always
nearing completion of that expanded
manuscript terrorists struck on 11
September 2001 and almost immediately I
received assignments dealing with the
global war on terrorism and I
temporarily had to shelve the Naval
Academy project I interviewed a few of
the survivors who were at the Pentagon
on 9/11 and then I was assigned to the
Navy's & 3 & 5 office in the Pentagon to
serve as a fly-on-the-wall
to collect records for the Navy's role
in Operation Enduring Freedom but I was
still allowed to work on that Academy
integration project part-time finally in
the fall of 2002 I completed an 1100
page manuscript covering the period 1872
to 1999 that went out to peer review to
some half a dozen scholars in the fields
of American history and naval history by
the spring of go three all the reviewers
submitted their comments and they all
agreed that that 1100 page manuscript
was too long and would have to be cut so
what I did was split the manuscript into
the first which numbered 400 pages is
the book you see here and the second
which I've interviewed many of you for
is is now at the University of Nebraska
Press where it's being considered for
publication so the the story through
1999 will be told but it'll take a
little while yet
although some might argue that the
graduation of an african-american from
Naval Academy was inevitable
Wesley Browns background ability
attitude and personality decisively
affected his own outcome having attended
high school played sports led the high
school cadet corps and held a job all at
the same time Brown was accustomed to
hard work on little sleep even before
coming to the Naval Academy his
experience in high school cadet corps an
army specialized training Reserve
Program familiarized them with some of
the military regiment regimentation he
encountered at the academy his
upbringing and schooling at Dunbar High
School and Howard University prepared
his mind and gave him the self-reliant
self discipline self-esteem and
self-confidence to handle not only
academics at the academy but also his
immersion for the first time and what
was previously an all-white world his
low-key attitude and cheerful
disposition earned him friendships among
fellow plebs and upperclassmen alight in
short Wesley Brown became the first
african-american graduate of the Naval
Academy because the time was right and
because he was the right man for the job
Wesley Brown's graduation received
international attention and made him a
celebrity for a little bit longer than
fifteen minutes in the black community
stories about his experiences here in
Annapolis were published in newspapers
news magazines like the New York Times
Washington Post Time Newsweek the
Pittsburgh courier the afro-american
Chicago Defender and a host of others
Browne himself wrote a story for The
Saturday Evening Post
ensign Todd shailu of the Taiwanese Navy
found The Saturday Evening Post article
so moving that he had it translated into
Chinese and published in his Navy's
official magazine more importantly
however Browns graduation was the first
step in transforming the Naval Academy
from a racist institution to one that
marks equal opportunity among its
fundamental tenets barrier breakers bear
the cost of transforming or advancing
society these costs include suffering
indignities and unequal opportunities at
the hands of prejudice people and racist
institutions
I thank commander Brown for bearing the
burden of leading the way for African
American Academy alumni who followed in
his footsteps one of the finest
compliments Brown has received was given
to him recently by Joe Burrell a 12-year
old student at mainland Preparatory
Academy in Lamarck Texas Joel having in
having been inspired by Wesley Brown's
example in a book on African American
first unfortunately not this book
pretended to be Wesley brown during a
recent living history assignment at
school he even got the full uniform thus
Wesley brown is not only inspired
generations of black Midshipmen he is
inspiring young people who perhaps will
one day become Midshipmen and now
without further ado I'd like to turn the
floor over to Wesley brown
well it's certainly an honor and I'm
very proud and humbled by all of this
attention most people don't get an
opportunity of reading a biography in
their lifetime and usually after you're
gone that the biographies come out those
of you that came here today to hear Bob
give away the book I'm sure you're
disappointed because he didn't he just
told you how he wrote the book and I'm
afraid you're going to have to read the
book for some of the details that I
think you'll find very interesting
incidentally Jimmy Carter did provide
the endorsement on the front of the book
in a corner there and I consider him one
of the finest individuals I've ever met
he has said several times in his book in
his books and at lectures at the academy
that while he was a southerner and he
played with black kids and more or less
on an equal basis growing up it was when
he came to the Academy and met me that
he began to think of african-americans
as equals and I can tell you that he was
one of many first classmen who had a
part in keeping me pumped up and and
wanting to stay and graduate Barb and I
have done this before and I try to
benefit from the questions and the other
things had happened the last time
unfortunately Bob didn't make it because
he had an accident I'm sure he'll tell
you about that later so I had to
pens [ __ ] but I didn't say all the nice
things that he did however it seems to
me that the questions that are asked
other than what Bob just said he he said
that very clearly and he's both a good
writer as well as a good historian
questions that I get quite often did I
live alone and that seems to be
something important to those of you have
questions I lived alone for the four
years but it was my choice and I didn't
get lonesome I didn't talk to the walls
and that type of thing
secondly the comparison was always made
how come West Point graduated its first
african-american in 1877 and I didn't
graduate from the Naval Academy until
1949 what's the difference and I think
that's very important because as a young
man in Dunbar High School I saw a West
Point cadet named James Fowler who
graduated in 1941 and I thought about
going through West Point and I got to
meet a couple more West pointers from
Washington DC from Dunbar High School
during that period of the 40s it just so
happened that Adam Clayton Powell was
voted into Congress as the second black
congressman in 1945 and he was very
interested in having some of the 10 the
Academy and graduate and that seemed to
be the great challenge to me and I
decided to try for the Naval Academy but
it all started back in the
Reconstruction period if you want to
call it that in quotes that after
getting freedom and citizenship and
voting rights the next natural thing was
trying to get permanent commissions from
the service academies in 1870 at James
Webster Smith and at West Point he was
there for number of years about six
years he didn't graduate that it's a lot
of fights a lot of court martials and so
forth and perhaps he received the
hardest time from his classmates rather
than the upperclassmen but I guess this
hazing probably came from prep schools
and software sophomoric groups that
seemed to dominate the service academies
in peacetime in particular the hazing
certainly made it tough to study I think
of that old expression when you're up to
your behind and snapping turtles and
crocodiles it's hard to remember that
your objective is to drain the swamp
so that no matter how good a student you
are if people come in interrupt you
during study hours and have a lot of
demerits have to do penalty drilling
roll cutters and that sort of thing it
does take a lot of energy and it does
take time and it affects your academics
if you look at the West pointers or
Naval Academy Midshipmen who didn't
graduate I don't think you'll find
anything wrong with their academic
preparation as Bob said the secret is
the timing you have to have the
qualifications but then the timing has
to be right and that's important there's
always always the question gee did I get
in any fights no I didn't but I was
prepared to I wasn't gonna let anybody
push me around physically on the other
hand there was the question of how many
of the the West pointers actually did
suffer physical attacks and and what
happened well there was one that is well
documented this was a fellow who was
there as a freshman when flipper was a
senior and Henry Oh flipper was the
first graduate in 1877 this fellow's
name was Whittaker Johnson see Whittaker
and there have been some public
television presentations on his
experience this particular experience he
failed to show off a muster and the
cadet officer of the day when ends the
see if perhaps he'd overslept
as it turned out found him unconscious
on the floor his legs were tied to his
bed he was lying in a pool of blood in
his shorts clumps of hair had been taken
out by shears or scissors so forth it
was a great deal of blood on the wall
and there was a threatening note this
desk and after that description you'd
say poor guy but it seems at Westpoint
decided that he should be court martial
because he was trying to bring dishonor
on the name of the of West Point and
they accused him of writing a note
himself well a number of years later the
court-martial was reversed they offered
to restore him the duty at West Point
but he thinking that too many years had
passed a few years ago President Clinton
did restore him to duty
promoted him to second lieutenant that's
the only case that I know of in terms of
physical assault but rumors exist there
were rumors about other cadets perhaps
were killed a list they were not true
there were rumors about some black
Midshipmen who was tied to a buoy out in
the seven river and when they finally
realized he was there they released him
he ran away and they never saw him again
bobert heard this from a number of
people and was unable to substantiate
that there had ever been such a person
but their loads and loads of rumors that
that get told one for example about me
was that the n-double-a-cp was pay me to
be there some fantastic
per diem and IIIi wasn't wasn't aware of
this and till one day I heard someone
say well we're going to make him earn
his money so I asked my first classmen
what are they talking about and they
told me about the rumor so he said this
isn't true isn't it you know twice
tonight well many many years later when
Bob sent out his question here one of my
16 company classmates gave Bob a nice
long letter and one of the things he
said well you know I never believed that
story about Wes that he was being paid
by the n-double-a-cp said I figured as I
really wanted a top student you know
they were gotten somebody with better
qualifications and west so he said I
don't think he got the money there but
my wife is resented this but I consider
this quite an honor
but essentially West Point was able to
graduate three cadets prior to 1900
second graduate 1887 unfortunately died
of heart attack at age of 30 and the
third 1889 now in the meantime what had
happened reconstruction was over there
was a election 1876 at the end of the
grant administration there were disputed
electoral votes and some deals were made
which resulted in Hayes becoming the
president and the federal troops leaving
the south and this was when these Jim
Crow and segregation laws started
initially the abolitionists and others
who looking for full citizenship
the right for the freely the newly
freely slaves started colleges a lot of
the historically black colleges such as
Atlanta University and others were
started around this time and West Point
the Naval Academy appointments and so
forth
were part of this overall effort the
Naval Academy did have Midshipmen who
started in 1872 1873 1874 the first to
incidentally were nominated by black
congressman and both were ministers one
guy was born in England Liverpool and
served in the Royal Navy and ultimately
I believe he settled in Buffalo but the
West Point nominees were appointed by
white congressmen the final Naval
Academy nominee was appointed in 1874
and he was from Mississippi the what
happened to these gentlemen after they
left the Academy is very interestingly
they had very fine experiences the
second fellow for example at the Naval
Academy became a doctor professors at
the Academy actually provided money for
his scholarship to the medical school at
Howard University he went back to South
Carolina and and practiced medicine
so between let's say 1900 and 1929
it was not considered politically astute
to nominate a black to either West Point
or the Naval Academy and it wasn't until
Oscar de priest became congressman from
Illinois that the appointment started
again the priest was a Republican
replaced by congressman Mitchell who had
a very very strong feeling that the
Naval Academy and West Point should be
integrated and he did nominate quite a
few to both schools he nominated Trivers
Bob mentioned earlier and another fella
called Johnson whose nickname was socks
the socks meant Socrates because he was
so brilliant he spent a lot of time
after after he was dismissed was the
David Taylor on model Basin and a number
of other naval architect positions so he
died I believe about three or four years
ago but he spent roughly about one year
at the academy before resigning so there
was some history there of West pointers
however graduating on a fairly regular
basis after Fowler there were two in
1943 one was killed in Italy was an
aviator there were two more in 44 145
two of the three were from Dunbar High
School
again and then one 10:47 so by the time
I was ready to graduate from the Naval
Academy
there had been eleven black graduates of
West Point now what's the difference
well first of all most obvious thing is
Annapolis is located in the south and
when I was coming along schools were
segregated I had to ride on the back of
the bus Rosa Parks would had the same
prop had the same problem here in
Annapolis
she had a Montgomery Alabama and it was
just quite a bit of difference in that
respect then say being in West Point
upstate New York
secondly the Navy always had black
sailors but no officers and the officer
setup was generally southern based many
of the Naval Academy Midshipmen came
from prep schools like Valley Forge or
Admiral Farragut and so forth and the
main source of officers for the most
part was the Naval Academy the army of
course had had other sources and in
particular and most importantly because
there was always the question what are
they going to do with you if you
graduate you're not going to be able to
serve on board ship it because the main
objective
objections to having black officers and
I mean this wasn't just the academies
but the public in general accepted this
the main objection was a you certain
certainly couldn't command white
enlisted
or officers under you and black enlisted
and we're not going to follow you ela
and the army or the Navy would feel much
better if white officers commanded any
black troops that were involved to
demonstrate this when flipper graduated
from West Point the army had a
regulation that said only white officers
can command troops in black units
Congress had established 24th and 25th
infantry 9th and 10th Calvary so that
blacks would have an opportunity to
serve in the peacetime forces and
anytime you see the Calvary riding to
the circle wagons of the settlers just
think that one of every four those
cavalry units were black or black but
they had white officers so when flipper
was about to graduate the Secretary of
the army had to change the regulation
that said black officers could not serve
Him black graduates and that was
breaking a very in a sense too that
opened it up the other thing was that
somehow other there seemed to be some
kind of stigma if a black person was in
your graduating class that meant that
your class was was something less than
the others that did not have black in in
their classes so that stigma was there
also but essentially it was very easy to
segregate the army numbers where you had
regiments or battalions or
companies and once the army established
those four units then all blacks of 107
the army had to serve in those units so
that in effect they had some place where
you serve in the Civil War there were
over 200,000 black soldiers and all
kinds of units field artillery Calvary
and infantry as well and they were
officered by officers by seven thousand
white officers but they also had about a
hundred and fifty black officers as well
except for the two Massachusetts
regiments and the and the Louisiana
regiments that were local troops as
opposed to US federal troops most of
these black officers were chaplains or
surgeons and in that regard one one
other thing Congress passed a law that
said in effect there was a lower pay
scaled established for blacks working
for the army it was very vaguely written
and as a result of this many of the
paymaster's assumed that it meant every
black who wore a uniform there was a
fellow from I think Baltimore name was
Augusta is an eminent doctor a surgeon
he was commissioned as a major and
assigned to a US Colored Troops and he
found to his horror that his pay was
less than the pay of a white private
since he was I didn't matter what his
rank was the paymaster refused to pay
well that was the first luck
the second was when he got there there
were two assistant surgeons white guys
and they didn't like the idea of working
for a black fella even in a
all black unit there for the army that's
wisdom detached him sent him to
Washington for recruiting duty at a time
when surgeons were hard to come by in
combat units they did allow him of
course to to give them a physicals and
so that the utilization in many cases
was not always ideal even if you did
have the qualifications so Bob's title
of the book goes beyond west Browns
graduation from the Naval Academy if you
look at the struggle for racial equality
look at breaking barriers there were
many many barriers to be broken many
many struggles that have taken place and
are still taking place in in many
respects so that I think you'll find the
book well worthwhile and I certainly
would hope that if you read this the
second book I should be on your list
awesome now I'll end my remarks at that
point I took almost as long as Bob and
will entertain any questions that you
have yes
did you get a little bit of reaction at
the african-american community here in
Annapolis when the announcement was made
that you'd be entering with the class of
49 and then a little bit of what when
you finally were able to come to
Annapolis okay well um very interesting
I reported here in the uniform on the
uniform had some trouble getting out of
the army
so I could be sworn in Navy not too long
after I arrived VJ they came and we had
a parade in an Annapolis and no question
I got all the cheers through the town of
Annapolis and obviously the town was
very supportive and I noticed little
things the tailor shop always got my
stuff back
perfect on time the barbershop see
people out in town they were they let me
know that they were happy to see me and
then of course Annapolis has changed
it's changed quite a bit in terms of the
sponsors programs many things that the
superintendent's decided if black
Midshipmen can't do that
none of the Midshipmen can do that and
that economic pressure helped to change
a lot of things in Annapolis itself that
happened also and the Army and Navy were
trying to integrate some places in the
south where at least onboard those
federal installations they were able to
establish policies were different from
those on in town
yes relationships inside
doing the same company for four years
and you have good relationships with
your classmates and another musical
company yes I would say without any
hesitation my 16th company classmates
were supportive I felt free to go in
anybody's room or they came in to see me
we worked together on assignments and
have no argument whatever I can't think
of any member of my class who was
negative in that regard and I would say
the same thing to some extent of the
first classmen the seniors the class of
47 Jimmy Carter's class in the 16th
company my problems were outside of the
16th company a few people but these are
more individuals for the most part that
had their own prejudices and that was a
general thing throughout the spirit
after 1877 did not want to sit by blacks
eat with them have them go to the same
movies restaurants transportation in
general and you just can't rationalize
that kind of prejudice I found out for
the first time since I had attended an
all-black school from kindergarten
through college I did not find out until
I came to the Naval Academy that there
were other prejudices
besides color or racial prejudice I
found there were people who were
prejudiced against Mexicans
Catholics Jews poles I never laughed at
a polish joke because if you have to
identify an ethnic person to make it
funny then it doesn't isn't funny but so
I did find out that they were there were
other people who suffered prejudice as
well oh okay yes sit down your
classmates
and we're not as gracious as six neat
company and to talk through what
happened during
I'm glad you asked that because we have
scheduled on the 3rd of June which will
be the 56th anniversary of our
graduation my class is making me the
honoree for that get-together originally
they had invited classmates along the
East Coast and the Midwest and some of
the others said hey we want to come too
so it's a nationwide thing and they're
expecting a good turnout of course a lot
of us are no longer here but they're
expecting that someone coming and I've
over the years I've had people call me
or talk with me and say you know I'm
really embarrassed and really sorry that
I didn't treat you a little better than
than I did when we were at the academy
you can't tell some people didn't want
to get in involves or get in trouble
with the upperclassmen
were not necessarily prejudiced just
looking out for number one then and not
getting any more grief than they had to
so interesting I had I received a letter
from a retired flag officer from the 4th
battalion who chose to ignore brown when
when they were Midshipmen together
because he was afraid that if he paid
attention to Brown he'd get in trouble
from racist Midshipmen and he wrote
saying that he was a shame and that's
the word to use the shame that he didn't
try to behave normally towards Brown and
be friendly or not depending on
personality and not worry about this
race thing so good
now Bob said you didn't have tested to
the stomach yes good yes actually speak
of the treatment you received in the
home but I was curious if you could
elaborate how much support you receive
as far as from the academic staff did
you encounter racism there as well or
were there were they very supportive of
you or the whole time you were at the
name of had well first of all when I was
here most of just about all of us took
the same courses except for language we
had a choice of language and everything
else was the same and of course that
gave the those who came from the prep
schools of military naval prep schools
like Valley foraging and Farragut a
break because they used the same text
books same quiz assist and all of that
and so he should have been well prepared
for academics for the the plebe year I
had no academic problems I know of no
case where any professor said anything
did anything that I didn't think was was
unprofessional or what I would expect
anywhere no argument whatever and I
don't know of any cases of any faculty
members who might have been involved in
any programs of that type I was in the
top half of my class but I must admit
the demerits that number of demerits
will drop you down I was pretty close to
the bottom in terms of conduct and then
a second area we used to call Greece
which meant aptitude for the service and
it's kind of a 4runner
of fitness reports when you're
commissioned that determine whether or
not you're promoted and that type of
thing I got a lot of low aptitude for
the service evaluations now I had no
argument on this first of all you can't
you can't protest them or object and
secondly I respect that person's right
to his own opinions I just hope that
maybe I can impress some other people to
balance that out but probably I might
have stood a little higher in my class
had I had the normal number of demerits
or aptitude for the service I was very
very low in those faculty had absolutely
nothing to do with that that was
strictly my military chain of command
boson cruises as well as at the academy
there was a case or a faculty member
expressed discontent that Brown was here
to a class Tom hudner
whose class of 1947 Medal of Honor
recipient for trying to save the life of
the first African American aviator
flying combat got killed during the
Korean War Tom hudner told me an
interview that he was in an English
class and and the English professor said
out loud in class referring to Wesley
brown that and then he used the n-word
we'll never get through and then he
talked about the last couple Midshipmen
that were here black Midshipmen and they
didn't get through either and he was
apparently free with his use of the
n-word in class that day and this really
upset hudner who was raised in Fall
River mass Massachusetts without
prejudice and his family and it's funny
there was one of the justifications used
for
separating James Lee Johnson who is a
came to the Naval Academy in 1936 was
under graded English papers he
apparently didn't do very well in
English and there was some it wasn't
clear whether this was made up or
whether he in fact did do poorly there
were there was evidence both ways but
I've always wondered whether it was the
same faculty member and I've never been
able to find out so if there was any any
prejudice Brown never experienced that
firsthand to my knowledge although
people might have felt that way they
kept it to themselves and they remained
professional about it too for the most
part we received a quiz maybe four out
of five days a week a written quiz and I
believe the quince peepers were retained
for some period of time so if there were
a congressional investigation if that
should come up why someone could second
yes or look over the shoulder but I I
don't feel that I had any academic
difficulties whatever and in that regard
as I said earlier you'll find that if
you look at the academic backgrounds of
those who graduated from West Point and
those who didn't graduate from the Naval
Academy you'll find they're pretty good
the Jimmy Fowler had graduated from
Howard University before he went to the
naval cabin to West when General Bo
Davis was within a year of graduating
from Western Reserve and I think didn't
socks Johnson have about two or three
years in Case Western that's right yeah
case Weston and he was no
Institute of Technology yeah yeah I
having been distinguished yeah but
essentially it's whether or not you you
have the time to study whether people
interfere now another thing is I found
that Bob mentioned I worked six nights a
week the Navy Department eight hours
eight hours a night when I was in high
school I didn't have a lot of time for
my studies and then an extra hour and a
half twice a week for a competitive
drill fortunately I wasn't colonel in
the last year's so I didn't have to a
whole lot of drilling since they had
their death but so I could read my stuff
and understand and retain it pretty well
now I was always a good tester there are
a lot of people had excellent grades but
we're not used to handling that kind of
academic program in the time constraints
you can't stay up all night at the
academies have to go to bed at taps you
get in trouble you get demerits so if
you're used to just taking whatever time
that it takes to learn the lesson you're
going to have trouble yes Jack I was
worried whether or not there were any
visionary mentors around that era maybe
yeah that would have been dreadful than
other people in the major department in
the cno's office you know the name
to come to mine of Zumwalt enamel Borda
stand out in naval history as people who
published and put out documents that
wanted to really enhance that
integration was there anyone there when
that lesson ground was at the earth
academy on that 45:49 timeframe that was
a visionary mentor I don't know about
mentor but Secretary of the Navy James
Forrestal Wright was a very large
proponent of integration his predecessor
Frank Knox who died in 1944 thought that
wartime was no time for integration and
he as much said so in letters and so
forth and so while Knox was still
secretary black women were not admitted
to the waves and and black officers and
sailors who had non Messman branch
billets couldn't expect to serve on
board ships except on segregated ships
and it's very difficult to train people
to serve on a ship let alone trying to
create a separate black Navy although
the Navy managed to do that with PC 1264
and destroyer escort Mason
but when Knox died and Forrestal came in
he not only wanted to give blacks better
opportunities in the Navy out of a sense
of fairness but he also had a pragmatic
sense it costs a lot of money to build
separate facilities to train blacks it
cost a lot of money to
deny the Naevia a certain proportion of
the American population 10 12 percent
and so he was able to sell it to the two
leaders like King and Nimitz on a
practical basis and that was a stepwise
adoption of integration they tried
putting African Americans and general
service billets on 10% of Uggs to make
up no more than 10% of auxilary vessels
10% of the crew and then a small
proportion of auxilary vessels as well
and when that succeeded they went on to
try to integrate all oxalá
vessels and then when at work combatants
and so forth and eventually in a
stepwise program that actually took
place over a couple of years i mean by
february 1946 on paper the navy was
integrated but Forrestal was able to
bring the Navy along quickly at the
Naval Academy for Brown himself there
were individual people who both his
upper classmen as classmates and his
officers tried to see that he got a fair
chance and objected to people who are
trying to give him a hard time because
he was black one of the most interesting
cases was Eugene Barham who's a class of
1935 graduate and a 4th battalion
company officer at that time he had been
born and raised on a plantation
in Louisiana's parents owned the
plantation he was from a family who
owned some of the biggest cotton farms
in that era area and he grew up driving
in his father's car and observing all
the African American sharecroppers and
horse and buggies having to pull off the
road and tip their hats when the car
passed by so he was 4th battalion
officer when when Brown was in a plebe
year and yet Barham even though he
didn't quite feel 100% good about an
african-american being there he'd been
through
world war two and he had been on
destroyer laughy when that ship nearly
got cut into by the Japanese battleship
he I during the night Battle of
Guadalcanal and he had seen a lot of
other action and I'm convinced that by
seeing all this action and seeing black
Messman and people from all walks of
life behave heroically it kind of helped
to subdue a lot of the prejudice he was
raised with basically I came to the
conclusion that he didn't want to see
anybody under his command whether it be
on a destroyer or in the 4th battalion
have unfair obstacles put in front of
him because of race or ethnicity so he
was sort of a reluctant advocate he
basically got a lot of reports from
upperclassmen saying that Browns room
was in disorder and this was an offense
punishable by demerits Class B offense
and what he would do was take the
reporting Midshipmen around to the
reporting midshipman zone room and then
compare it to Browns room and almost in
every case Browns room within much
neater order so he would tear the report
up now filing a false delinquency report
was a Class A offense punishable by
separation from the Academy
Barham never took it that far he thought
that that would cause more trouble than
solve problems but there it was he was
he was taking positive action where as I
have to say his predecessors in the 30s
and the executive department did not but
but mostly it was at the top level of
the Navy department secretary Forrestal
and then people here at the Naval
Academy who knew Brown and I have to say
there was a larger minority of people
who are interested in seeing him get a
fair chance than there were interested
in running him out
but those were the ones who provided
help I'm not sure I would use the word
mentor but I would certainly say support
every farce Forrestal certainly did many
many innovative things and was an
outstanding Secretary of the Navy and of
course he later became Secretary of
Defense to add to what Bob said there
had an experience where came back from
class one day and my room was really in
disorder gross disorder books all over
the floor my bedding pulled out and so
forth and I was really very angry and
the officer that they came by with the
messenger and I said oh here it goes so
I stood at attention and he came in he
walked around and looked he looked at me
and he said did you make your room up
today and I said yes sir he said I
thought so and he walked out and I'd
made me feel very good for for a couple
of days anyway
good question that's not you negate that
you see you want to first start to the
right or research about the segregation
of label that's question
what do you think it is and therefore
you manual how would you how were you
receiving me as a as a personal coming
graduate what how we received in the
Navy's first black borders first of all
I think Bob was speaking a very limited
sense with regard to books or magazine
articles and so forth and blacks in the
Navy or in the military in general there
were some books but not a whole lot and
they didn't sell very well so very few
people got to see them libraries for
example didn't buy them when available
people just didn't buy enough to create
a market now I've brought some things
here and when we break as we start
signing books and so forth let's take a
look at these books that I brought and
you can see that they are all post-world
War two and maybe even as late as 1999
and so forth I brought a couple of Bob's
books too at least the not the book but
the dust cover so as you can see and by
the way he did just recently receive
recognition from the Navy League for a
shield and sword Navy and in the Persian
Gulf so that's another ward for him and
I'm sure he's going to get one for this
book too now your question again was how
were you received how was I received
okay well I went in the civil engineer
Corps the Navy was very difficult to get
in and for the most part the
Naval Academy siblings mio cuore
officers were in about the top 5% of
their class prior to world war ii world
war two came and it was decided to give
reference for supply in civil engineer
Corps whose eyes or other physical
ailments prevented them from being
physically qualified for liners surface
warfare and so during World War two that
was the way CC was determined well I'd
always wanted to be an engineer civil
engineer it applied to Rensselaer for a
scholarship when I was in high school my
high school yearbook says that was my
ambition to be a civil engineer and I
decided to try for it if not I would
have gone into aviation or submarines
the aviation was one of my top subjects
too as it turned out I was able to get
CC quite as a result of the air force's
entrance on the scene when we were about
to graduate class of 49 Air Force was
able to get president Secretary of
Defense to give them an allocation of
the Naval Academy graduates of that that
year plus 49 and so the Air Force said
well we only want the top graduates we
don't want the guys down at the bottom
and the Naval Academy says how in the
world can a top graduate even think of
volunteering for the Air Force
there's Air Force says we don't want any
draftees we want volunteers volunteers
so anyway they argue back and forth like
the Army Navy game and then finally
but the decision was reached and the
decision was that the Air Force would
have two hours to speak to the senior
class two hours one Friday night and
that would be it and whoever volunteered
would go to the Air Force so anyway
we're all there and Air Force group
comes in and there's a four-star general
and a three-star general and a two-star
general and a one-star guidance he
started shaving it and so the four-star
guy gets up and says well I was on the
football team that beat Navy and 1934
the same as the Commandant of Midshipmen
and he looked this guy he's got four
stars the common artist got four strikes
and then and he sits down you know he he
didn't have a script he remembered that
but the next guy gets up and he says
what now I played lacrosse you know I'm
pretty big guy and so forth and I was on
the team and such and such and I played
against Don Montgomery and he said now
I've got three stars and John's got
three stripes and I understand he's been
selected for captain but let's give Don
a head you know so this guy goes there
and this goes on for about 35 minutes
and they get up and go out and the
mission are looking at one another and
the next morning there's a mob of people
outside the car dies of his who want to
sign up for air force
so because they didn't they didn't
element when these guys am sorry shaving
they've only got nine or ten years of
service they're going to be around for a
while but but anyway so the Navy says
well we can't have this so what we're
going to do we're going to allocate as
we normally do eight percent of Marine
Corps six percent to supply three
percent to CC and the eight percent of
the Air Force has to get we're going to
take one-third of the quota from each
third of the class so each one gets some
good guys and some bad guys so there
were I think maybe a hundred eighty guys
who wanted a civil engineer Corps and
they're a bunch of papers on the desk
and if you got one with a number on it
you win
otherwise you you only got one choice
you could pick civil engineer and Air
Force and that is how I ended up with
some ladies dear Court and that is how
they handle that as far as I know until
the Air Force receive their own
graduates but it was weird it was so
quiet and you can see the heads go like
like in a tennis match you know